[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANITHA VIJAYKUMAR:
TensorFlow Lite
is a lightweight
machine learning
library for mobile
and embedded devices.
DAN GALPIN: Hi, I'm Dan
Galpin, and I'm here
with Anitha Vijaykumar.
She's a technical program
manager at TensorFlow Lite.
Your background is
largely in infrastructure.
How did you make the
jump from infrastructure
to machine learning
with TensorFlow?
ANITHA VIJAYKUMAR: So I've
been doing infrastructure
for a very long
time, and one day I
heard a talk from Jeff Dean
on how computers can see cats.
And so this was something
really profound,
that we enabled machines to
actually have vision and see
something.
And so I tried a few
code labs in TensorFlow,
did a few programming
and machine learning,
and became interested
and moved in.
DAN GALPIN: So we already
have TensorFlow Mobile.
What was the motivation for
developing TensorFlow Lite?
ANITHA VIJAYKUMAR: This
is a great question.
TensorFlow Light should
be viewed as an evolution
of TensorFlow Mobile.
TensorFlow Lite supports a
subset of operations today,
and going forward, the
entire mobile support
should be on TensorFlow Lite.
DAN GALPIN: How did we decide
which operations to support?
ANITHA VIJAYKUMAR: So we talked
to a lot of partner teams,
the mobile vision team,
and then within Google, we
talked to our Android
partners, and we came up
with a list of models
that we wanted to support.
And then we said,
we want to have
a subset of operants
in the vision space,
a few models on the text,
and a demo, light model
on the speech.
So TensorFlow Lite supported
flavors of these three models,
and going forward,
we will extend that.
DAN GALPIN: So how
did we approach
the problem of improving
load times by comparison
to full TensorFlow?
ANITHA VIJAYKUMAR:
So we use something
called flat buffers, which is
again an open source Google
initiative.
They allow for really
fast load times,
and they don't
need unmarshalling,
and so using these
techniques helps
us to ensure that we can
have very low latency
and load the models faster.
DAN GALPIN: So
TensorFlow Lite uses
a model that has been
trained with TensorFlow.
Now, how does a
TensorFlow model actually
use in TensorFlow Lite, then?
ANITHA VIJAYKUMAR: So you start
off with a regular TensorFlow
model, generate a
model just like you
would do in normal TensorFlow.
So have your
GraphDef checkpoints.
And you go through an additional
step of freezing the graph.
This is also standard
TensorFlow operation, nothing
specific to Lite at this point.
But once you have
a frozen graph,
once you have a frozen
model, then you convert it,
you feed it into a
TensorFlow Lite converter,
and once you've converted to
a TensorFlow Lite converter,
you get what is
called a .lite file.
With this .lite file, it can
be fed into an interpreter,
and using the interpreter, you
can run your model inference
on the device with
TensorFlow Lite.
DAN GALPIN: What techniques
can developers use
to make their models smaller?
ANITHA VIJAYKUMAR: We
use quantization, mainly.
So quantization
models are-- usually,
neural networks are
resistant to noise,
and so we can get
better computation
and use smaller memory if
we use 8-bit quantization.
At the price of accuracy,
paying a price for accuracy.
So what you could
do is you could
train the model with
fake quantization nodes,
like we did with MobileNet,
and get better results when
you actually run your
inference on the device.
When we did quantization
and we measured
the results, what we found
was that MobileNet is about 4x
smaller than its flawed and
even speed it's about 50%
faster than the flowed
version of the model.
So this was really great results
that we saw with quantization.
DAN GALPIN: And so in terms
of developing TensorFlow Lite,
what surprised you
about the process?
ANITHA VIJAYKUMAR: So when
we started the development
of TensorFlow Lite, we
had an audacious goal
of hitting a very small
memory size of being
at least 300k or lower.
And to date, just
the base interpreter
is about 70 kilobytes,
and with operators loaded
is under 300 kilobytes.
So we are at least
15 times smaller
than traditional
TensorFlow, and so we
are really excited about it.
DAN GALPIN: We also
announced the Neural Networks
API in Android.
Now, how does
TensorFlow Lite support
this kind of acceleration?
ANITHA VIJAYKUMAR:
So we announced
it a couple of days
back, beta versions
of Android neural network API.
And TensorFlow Lite has
hooks for Neural Network API.
Using the Neural
Network API, you
can leverage custom hardware
accelerators on your device.
So if you have a DSP,
the application developer
doesn't have to worry about it
and still write his TensorFlow
Lite program, and if there's
an API and a specific hardware,
your instructions
can be accelerated
using that hardware.
DAN GALPIN: So if
developers want
to experiment with TensorFlow
Lite, how can they get started?
ANITHA VIJAYKUMAR: We
would love for developers
to start experimenting
with TensorFlow Lite.
The tensorflow.org
has a mobile web page,
and you can see
it's all revamped.
And so there's a lot of data
on TensorFlow Lite over there.
You can also download the
source code from GitHub.
It's under
contrib/lite currently.
And there's tons
of documentation.
There's a model that
you can download.
There's a demo application
that you can download
and get started immediately.
DAN GALPIN: Great.
Well, thank you so much,
Anitha, for talking to me.
Once again, this is Dan Galpin,
reporting for the Developer
Show here from GDD India.
Thanks for watching
the Developer Show.
Catch up on the TL;DR and
additional interviews from GDD
India right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]